please welcome my pain
I quite you're very much bilingual right
yeah so I'm International you're a lot
of language is growing up in Sweden I
grew up with all kinds of cultures and
so a lot more than Swedish and English I
know some words in Persian like
fiddles that means Santa Claus could be
banished maybe okay
oh look at that I think I still I well
let's go for English okay let's do it
for Bill okay because everything his
Norwegian is not really that I mean you
as I mention it you started out as a
rapper yes
who told you that um the guys in school
they were just like you have an American
accent you look like a stereotypical
rapper you should rap so to be cool with
the guys I would always rap and
freestyle and try to compete with them
but it really started in kindergarten
they told us to write a speech and they
and I wrote a speech that went like I
want to be a movie star to Hollywood
I'll go I'll sing with all the movie
stars and star in every show it's cool
I'm almost there but it's it's so you
actually you just started out rapping in
in kindergarten that was back in the
America exactly you lived in Rhode
Island in Rhode Island how was that kind
of well I went to Catholic school it was
very strict we couldn't wear earrings we
didn't take showers after gym we went to
gym class with our school uniform on so
when I came to Sweden it was very
liberal you know like people took
showers after gym and they were just
walking around naked and I told my mom I
was like I can't do this and then the
students went got together and called
well told a teacher that I wasn't taking
a shower after gym so they told my
mother and I was just like I'm scared of
nudity like nudity was a big problem for
me as growing up you know so it was very
liberal here and kind of strict there
because it's more date like I lived in a
dangerous neighborhood next to public
housing and stuff like that so it was
like you had to like keep an eye out on
your kids and neighbors did too so so so
we did so you felt like coming here and
having to shower in school it was like
it that was like a big deal yeah it was
a big deal because I wasn't used to like
the kids here they walk hurt like they
said I think at the kitchen table nude
you know I mean sometimes and I was just
like that's wrong you don't do that like
God can see you so you're worried that
your this gold faring child I mean that
sometimes in the bathroom I'll be like
is he watching me
no I'm just kidding no I wasn't
god-fearing no you you grew up partly in
Sweden and now you're back in America
yeah I'm back and forth I have an
apartment in Stockholm but I've been on
the road so I've been back and forth
between Sweden and the US well what is
your relationship with Sweden this this
how is that it's like a husband you know
sometimes you have problems but you love
the husband you know like sometimes I
get depressed cuz it's gray and you talk
about that a lot you know what I mean
there's a lot of talk about oh the Great
Depression or the Great Depression you
know like you spend a lot of time
complaining here when there's not that
much to complain about you get motivated
to do art without like having economic
financial problems you know what I mean
so it's like it's very motivational here
in a way what would you say that your
mother has been to she's meant a lot she
worked so hard for me you know to give
me what I want and to raise me to become
a good woman I would say and I'm an
extension of her you know like when I
look in the mirror now I see her more
and more and I just want to carry her
legacy on as a positive person she was
very like a goddess to me you know I
looked up to her she was she she's very
beautiful and very soft-spoken and she
never yelled at me so I appreciate her a
lot and your mother did support you
becoming a musician definitely she's
like girl you can sing you know she
loves my music and she knows all of my
songs and she always did that's why I
feel a sense of security and my
musicianship because she was always
there for me and she didn't live out her
dreams through me you know she used to
sing back
the day her and her friend had a West
African club in Rhode Island you know
she sang there but she never like pushed
me to do it she was like if you want to
do it you can do it and you're good at
it too so and you can play as loud as
you want yeah I used to scream
belt out Mariah Carey songs as a child
and did you learn instruments as well no
unfortunately yeah did you learn to read
music yeah I went to like a music high
school but I learned some of it but I
would just say that it comes more
natural to me
I just channel whatever I want to do and
then it comes out as a rapper do
improvised ooh do you like could you
improvise something now or is it do you
have to plan it or write it down and do
you I usually plan it and write it down
but here I'm on this show sitting next
to bill it's so trill feeling so real
next to this politician feeling so
unique like a musician I'll get better
at it
you're going to do the song for us now
yeah it's it's just the song that we
heard a bit of it here yeah it's called
don't wait yes I know I've heard that
it's become very popular in the weddings
yeah they want me to sing our weddings
all the time I haven't done any weddings
yet but yeah I don't want to become the
wedding singer yeah what's it about it's
about friendship and like living your
life to the fullest never settling and
it's dedicated to all my friends
they've been there for me through thick
and thin do you live your life to the
fullest yourself I would say that yeah
please welcome John please